on va retrouver enora malagré et
christophe carrière ils sont là alors
vous voyez quand on mange des sushis
comme ça dans les restaurants japonais
il ya souvent des bateaux comme ça il
faut mettre tout ça sur des bateaux donc
on s'est dit nous ils vont être en sushi
géo et nora et christophe carrière sur
le bateau voilà merci on avait besoin du
bateau merci beaucoup
alors est ce qu'on a et n'aura et
christophe carrière s'il vous plaît ce
qu'on peut les avoir franck bronca à
enora mais elle n'est pas du tout
ressenti et regarde
ah ouais c'est vrai mais elle a dû à la
justice alors un ça va
oui j'ai froid et couvrez les couvrait
les un peu les mains mais c'est pas
grave on y va on y va on est on est sur
le bateau on est sur le pont et
christophe carrière mais j'ai pas
compris j'ai pas compris la règle non
plus alors la règle et dressa vous avez
joué vous allez jouer pour hâter un
quelqu'un du public qui va jouer pour
une tablette
giuly enora malagré jouera pour jessica
smellit elle est où jessica je suis cac
et la voilà christophe carrière
christophe carrière joueurs pour yasmine
car à yasmine paul quinn yasmina les
eaux à l'aller on avait voulu aller
celui celui qui à la fin de la traction
aura sauvé le plus de boulettes
japonaise sachez son anonymat ses pales
sont avariés un discours très bien et
bien fera gagner la table est d'accord
mais fausse ne pensez pas avoir peur
penser à sauver des boulettes
ouais ça va ça va être champion d'accord
mais celui là j'ai très peur pour vous
mais je vous aime quand même ouais ça
allez on y va
c'est parti ah ouais déjà là où la merde
on s'attend donc à des données vous
optez non vraiment on va se tenir mais
est allé voilà s'alarmer pour acheter
des bateaux c'est à dire le bateau oui
oui il est tout perdu naquit le sol
algérien perdu du tout oui oui mais pour
l'instant c'est normal c'est la sauce
qui coule vous allez nous allons faire
des commentaires dans toute infraction
même bateau avec nora énorme savoir et
et ouaddou moi attendons et nos vins
savoir salon et nous ça va ça va alors
moi ça c'est l'art de moi je suis là
c'est rien voilà je vais vraiment sale
seyassah monte mais non mais non mais
non ça vaut que dal a regardé dhorasoo a
tombé tard à sauver des boules s wear
les soirées boulette qui est d'accord
j'ai sauvé les boulettes les bons lots
jamais la boule a dit nora et toi tu
aimes et voulait attendre
ma culotte surmonter à son travail
j'en ai partie maman ça va non
excusez-moi christophe carrière de la
main droite à cloches ne jure pas de moi
et toi c'est bien de terminer l'écriture
allez-y
selon toi c'est bon les gers et toutes
les doublettes à leur attention
on affaire à pois voulais être dans un
instant qu'il est c'est bon alors je te
carrière est ce que vous avez sauvé les
boulettes y en a qui croient que oui oui
oui oui oui j'ai même le riz
elle rase les mollets dies c c'est donc
c'est donc il ya fini mais je vous dire
allez on offre aussi une tablette à
jessie cave